[Music]
okay everyone I'm Brenda Washington I'm
super excited to be at Google Cloud next
this year let's learn what's next to the
eyes
[Music]
to make some postcards right with AI
we'll start off just by entering some
freeform texts just something wild do
you want to generate text and images for
do you think I'm gonna go with something
like Chicago since I'm from there
and Sunset and lastly some puppies who
doesn't love puppies
[Music]
you of your postcard
we got our postcard and our little text
we're gonna go wiggle this
[Music]
hey guys hey how are you doing good good
so can you tell me a little bit more
about what's going on here sure this is
the concierge the concierge is capable
to answer any question related to the
event so you want to give it a try yeah
can you recommend some gen AI session so
find you something you can click on this
it gives you the link directly amazing
and it's a session we can navigate you
towards everything love this really like
this we all know AR is the latest
technology out here so what is next it's
going to be lit
[Music]